- Yeah.
- So would you do a reboot?
Would y'all do it?
- We talk about this all the time.
We wanna do a reunion special.
Like a reason that everyone in the office
has to reunite for some reason,
like a one-time special episode.
- Like a movie!
Like a reunion movie.
- Like a movie.
Yeah, because I think
a reboot would be hard.
At the end of the series, spoiler alert
for anyone who's still
in the middle of it,
but some of the people
don't end up staying
at the paper company anymore.
They move on, they move away.
And so to manufacture some reason why
we're all working there
again I think would be odd.
But I think there is a reason that
we could all reunite in some other way.
So that's what we're--
- We have some ideas.
- That's what we want.
Call us.
- Call us NBC.
- NBC.
- Email us.
- I think it would be so good.
Like I said, it's just
got such a new life.
Like a younger age are getting
into these characters, it's really cool.
- And on a selfish level, I would like
to work with all those people again.
I'd like to have us
all in a room together.
- Yes!
- It's such a great
chemistry, great vibe, yeah.
- I teared up when I got here
because your security guy,
Joseph outside, did security
for "The Office" for seven years.
We saw him every day.
- We gave Joseph a big hug.
- We gave him a big hug.
He used to help me when
my daughter came to set.
I had like a little, you
know the little pink car
you push your kid around
in and it's really loud,
it's like (imitates clanking).
- Yeah, and everyone loves you.
- Everyone loves you.
I would like push her around,
and Joseph would like help me take it out
and set it out, and he
was just a sweetheart.
But I would love to see everyone again.
- It would be amazing.
- We might
have to steal Joseph for
that week of shooting,
if you don't mind, we want everyone.
- That's okay, I'm okay with that.